[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
janna pareigis zehn guten abend und
herzlich willkommen neben ihr steht
norbert lehmann von ihnen gibt es gleich
viel fußball
der ukraine krieg ein großes thema heute
aber auch die deutsche innenpolitik
sorgt für schlagzeilen
paukenschlag bei den linken die ko
vorsitzende susanne hennig will so tritt
mit sofortiger wirkung zurück
marin foul vor dem fall die ukrainischen
soldaten wollen offenbar aufgeben bei
freiem geleit
und streit um schwere waffen für die
ukraine die bundeswehr meldet wir können
nichts abgeben sonst sind wir nicht mehr
einsatzbereit
der rücktritt kam überraschend susanne
hennig weil so ist mit sofortiger
wirkung nicht mehr parteichefin der
linken die partei erschüttern zurzeit
bericht über sexismus vorfälle das mahnt
der hennig weil so auch als einen der
gründe dafür dass sie hinwirft ich will
so führte die linke seit mehr als einem
jahr gemeinsam mit janine wissler heute
abend trifft sich der parteivorstand
andrea maurer berichtet um 13 uhr 31
erklärt susanne hennig welt so
schriftlich ihren rücktritt vom
parteivorsitz
sie nennt persönliche gründe aber auch
die jüngsten missbrauchsvorwürfe in der
partei der umgang mit sexismus in den
eigenen reihen hat eklatante defizite
unserer partei offen gelegt ich
entschuldige mich bei den betroffenen
und unterstützer aller anstrengungen die
jetzt nötig sind um aus der linken eine
partei zu machen in der sexismus keinen
platz hat nachdem der spiegel
missbrauchs vorwürfe öffentlich gemacht
hat gibt es in der linken es geht um
sexuelle belästigung nötigung
machtmissbrauch auch der ehemalige
lebensgefährte der ko parteichefin
janine wissler hier verpixelt links im
bild wird beschuldigt unter dem hashtag
linke me to sammeln sich seit tagen wut
und persönliche geschichten mehr als 60
betroffene sollen sich inzwischen beim
linken jugendverband gemeldet haben die
rheinland pfälzische landesvorsitzende
fordert nach hennig wels rücktritt
weitere konsequenzen meines erachtens
nach muss die ganze partei da
konsequenzen treffen das heißt wir
müssen das debattieren wir müssen
ehrlich zueinander sein und meiner
meinung nach müsste der ganze partei
vorstand neu gewählt werden ein jahr ist
es her dass hennig welt so und wisla
parteichefin wurden was folgten ein
tennis welt so die schwierigste phase in
der geschichte unserer partei
richtungsstreit flügelkämpfe
wahl-debakel partei und fraktion werden
von ihrem rücktritt heute dennoch
überrumpelt ja wir haben eine
zugespitzte situation ich weiß dass der
parteivorstand heute abend tagt um
schlussfolgerungen aus der
gesamtsituation auch den mito vorwürfen
zu ziehen aber dass susanne henning welt
sodann heute diesen schritt gegangen ist
war für mich eine überraschung
zur stunde kommt der parteivorstand nun
zur sondersitzung zusammen es soll um
die missbrauchsvorwürfe gehen und
weitere konsequenzen
weitere konsequenzen theo koll was
bedeutet der rücktritt der partei
schaffen hennig weise für die linke es
ist wieder erzwungene blick auf den
politischen scherbenhaufen der
linkspartei zwar führt er nicht weil so
auch private gründe für den rücktritt an
aber wenn man ihre erklärung ließ dann
finden sich in den zentralen
kritikpunkte nimmer formulierungen im
plural also in der mehrzahl wir haben zu
wenig von dem geliefert was wir
versprochen haben und sie spricht von
der notwendigkeit neuer gesichter
unglaubwürdig zu sein das dürfte
zumindest den druck auf ihre
mitvorsitzende wissler weiter erhöhen
die sich ja eh schon kritischen fragen
stellen muss nicht zuletzt wegen ihres
verhaltens bei den missbrauchsvorwürfen
das schlechte abschneiden bei der
bundestags und dem saarland war die
parteiinternen querelen der ungelöste
richtungsstreit die partei steht aktuell
nicht weit vom abgrund entfernt und die
verantwortungsübernahme jetzt der einen
tschechien dürfte ein großes
fragezeichen auch in der andere
führungskräfte setzen oder wie es der
fraktionsvorsitzende eben formuliert hat
es brauche eine personelle neubesinnung
einschätzung von theo koll dankeschön
schauen wir in die ukraine wo die
russische großoffensive neues leid
bringt
73 luftangriffe meldet moskau allein in
der vergangenen nacht die meisten im
osten der ukraine die graue linie die
zeit den frontverlauf an verschiedenen
stellen versuchen russische einheiten
die ukrainische verteidigung zu
durchbrechen aus der umkämpften
hafenstadt mario pohl kommt ein
dramatischer hilferuf volker check
diese kinder führen ein leben unter der
erde in irgendwelchen tunneln auf dem
riesigen gelände des stahlwerks in
mariupol gefilmt haben dass kämpfer des
ukrainischen ultranationalen regiments
als oft dort wo russische bomben
wahrscheinlich nicht hinkommen das
hoffen auch ihre eltern gemeinsam mit
500 verletzten und mit ukrainischen
soldaten harren sie dort aus aber die
zeit wird knapp der kommandeur der
marine infanteristen appelliert an die
staatsführer der welt
das ist unser appell an die welt das
kann der letzte appell unseres lebens
sein wir haben wahrscheinlich nur noch
wenige tage vielleicht nur stunden der
feind ist uns weit überlegen 10 zu 1
bitte helft uns hier rauszukommen und
bringt uns in einen drittstaat
oder aus dem kreml diese
machtdemonstration
präsident putin feiert sich und russland
im kreis der militärs mit dem
erfolgreichen start einer neuen
interkontinentalrakete typ salat sie hat
eine reichweite von 18.000 kilometern
und kann atomsprengköpfe tragen
diese wirklich einzigartige waffe wird
das kampf potenzial unserer streitkräfte
stärken zuverlässig die sicherheit
russlands vor äußeren bedrohung
gewährleisten und diejenigen die in der
hitze rasender aggressiver rhetorik
versuchen unser land zu bedrohen zweimal
nachdenken lassen im osten des landes
nehmen die angriffe weiter zu auch in
kharkiv
andré oleg und juri drei junge
bombenentschärfer werden bei der arbeit
gefilmt russische fliegerbombe die nicht
gezündet haben das war am donnerstag am
sonntag waren sie wieder im einsatz die
bombe ging hoch alle drei tot
fassungslosigkeit und entsetzen bei den
familien und kollegen das ultimatum für
das stahlwerk in mario pohl ist
inzwischen abgelaufen die soldaten und
hunderte zivilisten sitzen offenbar nach
wie vor im werk fest der versprochene
flucht korridor hat sich am abend ein
stückchen geöffnet dutzende von frauen
und alten steigen in die busse um die
umkämpfte stadt zu verlassen
heute also neuer versuch eines flucht
korridors aus mario pohl dominik
löschmeister für uns in der ukraine hat
es wirklich geklappt konnten menschen
aus der belagerten stadt heraus gebracht
werden
ja geplant war ja dass 90 busse 6000
menschen aus dieser belagerten stadt
heraus bringen frauen kinder ältere
menschen nach ukrainischen angaben haben
es aber nur wenige busse geschafft dort
loszufahren und es sind auch nur so
wenige menschen in sicherheit gebracht
worden eine genaue zahl wurde bisher
nicht genannt die menschen die jetzt aus
mario pohl rausgebracht werden sollen
nach sapori cia kommen das ist 200
kilometer entfernt und von der ukraine
kontrolliert man muss die situation in
mario pohl als sehr katastrophal
bezeichnen es gibt dort kein strom kein
wasser keine lebensmittel und diese
flucht korridore sind in der
vergangenheit hier auch immer
gescheitert entweder einen beschuss
durch die russischen truppen oder dass
die menschen gar nicht zu den bussen
kommen konnten und man muss sehen
100.000 menschen harren in dieser stadt
noch aus also auch 90 busse werden das
problem das leid dieser menschen nicht
lösen aus der ukraine damit löschmeister
dankeschön und
der krieg in der ukraine beobachten die
nato-mitglieder estland lettland und
litauen mit besonderer sorge zum auftakt
ihrer reise dorthin hat außenministerin
bernburg ihren baltischen kolleginnen
noch einmal den beistand der nato
zugesichert europas sicherheit sei
untrennbar mit der sicherheit des
baltikums verbunden wer aber machte auch
die position deutschland zur lieferung
schwerer waffen in die ukraine klar
andere partner liefern jetzt gepanzerte
fahrzeuge ich möchte ich hier und
deutlich sagen das ist auch für uns kein
tabu auch wenn es in der deutschen
debatte manchmal so klingt wir haben
deswegen solchen lieferungen ja bereits
auch zugestimmt aber
kurzfristig ist bei uns nichts vorhanden
was wir jetzt wirklich schnell und
unverzüglich liefern können und das
genau ist die frage die im raum steht
hat die bundeswehr nun schwere waffen
also für ein panzer die sie derzeit im
bären könnte nein betont das
verteidigungsministerium vor allem geht
es bei der diskussion um den
schützenpanzer marder der zwar als
veraltet aber auch als bewährt gilt 370
marder hat die bundeswehr insgesamt
davon sind wohl nur rund 250
einsatzfähig gut die hälfte davon sind
den nato einsätzen gebunden und für die
übrigen hat die bundeswehr kaum noch
munition viel spielraum bleibt da nicht
berichtet ein reporter
wendig und wehrhaft so preis die
bundeswehr ihren zu kalten kriegs zeiten
konzipierten schützenpanzer marder ein
teil ist derzeit in gemeinsamen
einsätzen gebunden etwa 1 liter und für
die ausbildung hiervon würde die ukraine
gern 100 stück haben dies sei heißt es
dazu aus der bundeswehr aufgrund der
aktuellen verpflichtungen vor allem für
die nato nicht möglich weil dann hätte
die bundeswehr nichts mehr um kräfte
entsprechend nach zu
nach zu schicken wir hätten keine
möglichkeit mehr auf eventualitäten zu
reagieren und dass du dir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit noch erheblich
schwächen eine kleinere zahl aber sei
denkbar vermutet militärexperte masala
die position dass wir keine mader geben
können erscheint mir nicht glaubwürdig
weil es sicherlich noch ein paar mader
in der umlauf reserve gibt also was
machen wir wenn ein marder beim training
kaputt geht wir schicken da einen neuen
hin und reparieren den alten dass es die
umlauf reserven und wie schnell wären
mader nutzbar für ukrainische soldaten
die bundeswehr verweist darauf dass
dieses wochen system maler eben ein
system es muss in der gesamtheit also
mit den lenkraketen die dazugehören mit
den entsprechenden handwaffen mit der
dazugehörigen munition für die maschinen
kanonen versorgt sein und es muss
technisch kriegs tauglich eingesetzt
werden können und das setzt eine gewisse
ausgeliefert jahr über herrscht
einigkeit bei fachleuten zweifel gibt es
daran dass dies ausschlusskriterium sei
auch diese ausbildung kann man ich
formuliere das mal so wenn es
erforderlich im schnelldurchgang
durchziehen von daher wäre dieses gerät
für die ukraine ausgesprochen wertvoll
gewesen vor allen dingen dann wenn man
diese entscheidung vielleicht vor fünf
wochen geführt hatte auch aktuell hieß
es heute vom verteidigungsministerium
sei keine lieferung aus
bundeswehrbeständen in die ukraine
vorgesehen wieder diesmal noch andere
schwere waffen und
mehr zur debatte um schwere waffen und
warum deutschland keine panzer in die
ukraine liefert finden sie auf zdf heute
und in der zdf- heute
bundesfinanzminister lindner warnt vor
einer weltweiten schuldenkrise besondere
risiken sieht dabei schwellen und
entwicklungsländern es müsse jetzt
reagiert werden lindner äußerte sich bei
der frühjahrstagung von iwf und weltbank
in washington
deutschland werde sich unter anderem an
einem internationalen treuhandfonds für
ärmere länder beteiligen dafür seien
darlehen von mehr als sechs milliarden
euro vorgesehen
die pipeline nord stream zwei das lange
als wirtschaftliche chance für
mecklenburg vorpommern
jetzt ist sie zu einem großen problem
geworden auch für ministerpräsidentin
schwesig sie habe das umstrittene
projekt projekte gegen alle warnungen
durchgepeitscht so der vorwurf und nicht
genug abstand zum russischen gasriesen
gazprom gehalten es gibt
rücktrittsforderungen heute äußerte sich
die ministerpräsidentin gegenüber dem
zdf zur kritik eine stadtfeld berichtet
im fokus der kritik die stiftung klima
und umweltschutz ihr auftrag
klimaprojekte fördern und vor allem die
vollendung der gaspipeline nord stream 2
hier in der staatskanzlei wurde die
stiftung anfang 2021 auf den weg
gebracht ministerpräsidentin manuela
schwesig hatte dabei mächtig druck
gemacht
der vorwurf heute das nord stream zwei
konsortium habe bei der gründung die
feder geführt zurück aus dem osterurlaub
räumt schwesig gespräche ein von diktat
will sie nichts wissen
natürlich ist es ganz normal dass man
wenn man einen solchen infrastruktur
projekt arbeitet dann auch mit dem
unternehmen spricht und vor allem auf
die interessen des landes schaut es ging
um arbeitsplätze im unternehmen
es ging auch um die sanktionen die trump
administration hatte sanktionen gegen
das megaprojekt angedroht die stiftung
sollte helfen die pipeline trotzdem
fertig zu stellen der landtag beschloss
fast einstimmig ihre gründung
mittlerweile hat sich die stiftung als
fehler bezeichnet und will ihre
auflösung für manche kommt diese
einsicht viel zu spät
ab mai soll ein untersuchungsausschuss
unter anderem klären was hat die
stiftung zur vollendung der pipeline
wirklich beigetragen und welche rolle
hat schwesig gespielt
noch eine folge des ukraine kriegs unter
pandemie die erzeugerpreise sind im märz
so stark gestiegen wie noch nie fast ein
drittel mussten die hersteller
inländischer produkte im schnitt mehr
bezahlen als vergangenes jahr für
rohstoffe und für energie besonders
deutlich waren die preissprünge bei
strom +
85,1 prozent heizöl wurde für gewerbe
und industrie in einem jahr um 100 30,8
prozent teurer erdgas sogar um 144 8
prozent weil er die halle an der börse
frankfurt heißt das beim einkauf mussten
noch tiefer ins portemonnaie gegriffen
werden genau das denn die erzeugerpreise
die sind ja sozusagen der vorbote für
die inflation normalerweise bekommen sie
nicht so viel aufmerksamkeit weil es
eben die preise sind die hersteller
sozusagen am fabriktor bezahlen also
noch bevor die produkte weiter
verarbeitet werden wenn sie aber so
durch die decke ging dann schaut man da
genauer hin dann nämlich davon ausgehen
dass die hersteller einen teil ihrer
höheren kosten an den endverbraucher
weitergeben und das bedeutet vermutlich
deutlich höhere lebenshaltungskosten
hauptverantwortlich für den preisschub
ist weiterhin die energie stark
angezogen haben aber auch die preise für
einzelne lebensmittel wie butter
rindfleisch und kaffee der ukraine krieg
beschleunigt den trend zu teureren
lebensmitteln ein sprung bei den
erzeugerpreisen war erwartet worden
nicht aber dass er so groß ausfällt
entspannung ist erst mal nicht in sicht
im gegenteil viele glauben das ende der
fahnenstange ist noch längst nicht
erreicht das sind ja keine guten
nachrichten danke valerie haller
es dauerte nur stunden dann war die neue
staatliche förderung für energiesparende
neubauten auch schon wieder weg rund
eine milliarde euro hatte die kfw vom
bund dafür bekommen bereits im januar
hatte es einen abrupten förderstopp für
neue häuser gegeben der hohe wellen
geschlagen hatte im kommenden jahr soll
es dann eine völlig neue überarbeitete
förderung für häuslebauer gehen
beim sek einsatz im nordosten von baden
württemberg ist ein polizist
angeschossen und verletzt worden
möglicherweise von einem sogenannten
reichs bürger nach angaben der polizei
eröffnete ein hausbewohner das feuer auf
die polizeikräfte als diese das anwesen
nach illegalen waffen durchsuchen
wollten mehrere menschen wurden
festgenommen
aus unbekannten gründen geriet das haus
in brand weitere details sind noch nicht
bekannt
und jetzt kommen wir wie versprochen zum
fußball zum dfb-pokal norbert steht er
seit gestern abend der erste fall ist
der sc freiburg nach dem 3 1 sieg beim
hsv die breisgauer zeigten sich beim
zweitligisten in allen belangen
überlegen das team von trainer christian
streich in der liga und im pokal auf
einer beeindruckenden erfolg spuren
historische freiburger jubel- nacht in
hamburg inklusive wasser dusche für
trainer christian streich der erstmalige
einzug der breisgauer ins
dfb-pokalfinale früh geebnet durch einen
kopf bald treffer von nils petersen nur
wenig später ein abgefälschter schuss
höfler zum 0 2 und zu allem überfluss
für die hsv fans trifft ebenfalls noch
vor der pause moritz fires durch
schwingender fuß den kopf von nico
schlotterbeck kripo verwandelt den
strafstoß zum 0 zu 3 das zweitligist hsv
kurz vor abpfiff durch glatze noch zum 1
3-endstand trifft kann die freiburger
finaleinzugs freude nicht mehr im
geringsten trüben
3 und heute abend entscheidet sich ja
gegen wen freiburg am 21 mai in berlin
im finale spielen wird rb leipzig die
beste mannschaft der rückrunde oder
union berlin nach drei liga siegen in
folge hoch motiviert
inzwischen gehört es im fußball zu den
guten gepflogenheiten dass der trainer
des favoriten in diesem fall leipzig den
gegner in den höchsten tönen lobt
bislang in die richtung atalanta bergamo
die wir auch gespielt erlebt haben
wir haben ansonsten viele viele spieler
die
eine gute power auf den platz bringen
laut bundesliga tabelle sind derzeit nur
fünf deutsche teams darunter auch
leipzig besser als union berlin das
heute mit der außenseiterrolle gar nicht
mal so unglücklich sein dürfte
nach nur einem punkt in den letzten
sieben bundesligaspielen hat sich die
abstiegsbedrohte bielefelder arminia von
coach frank kramer getrennt nachfolger
wird torwarttrainer marco kostmann
ja gestern abend liverpool du singt
manunited mit 14 0 und zu beginn ein
richtiger gänsehautmoment in der siebten
spielminute gedachten die fans beider
mannschaften united star cristiano
ronaldo der um dem tod seines jüngsten
sohns trauert und nicht mitspielen
konnte 60 sekunden applaus und gesänge
als zeichen der anteilnahme
und zum schluss noch das tennisspieler
und stelle spielerinnen aus russland und
belarus dürfen beim turnier in hamilton
nicht antreten wegen des angriffskriegs
auf die ukraine das hat der englische
veranstalter hat entschieden
die lottozahlen an diesem mittwoch
schauen wir doch auf die gewinnzahlen
lauten 10 16 19 20354 und 40 die
superzahl ist die drei weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
schauen wir mal aufs wetter bei den
einen bleibt es morgen trüb bei den
anderen scheint wieder die sonne wie es
bei ihnen wird das erfahren sie gleich
von katja horneffer bettina schausten
hat um 21.45 das heute schon mal für sie
auf wiedersehen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute zogen von osten
wolken heran und die brachten regen mit
in sachsen in sachsen anhalt in berlin
und in brandenburg und ein schmales
wolkenband hier über westeuropa löste
sich im laufe des tages mehr und mehr in
wohlgefallen auf diese dichteren wolken
über dem nordosten die haben wir auch
noch in der nacht da kann es auch hier
und da noch ein bisschen regnen im süden
ist es dagegen klar und die temperaturen
sinken auf sechs grad in der lausitz am
niederrhein und an der nordsee küste
deutlich kälter wird am alpenrand da
sinken die werte bis minus 1 grad also
in den frost und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen bei zehn grad hier
zum beispiel thüringen und maximal 20
grad am oberrhein und damit wird auch
klar wo es morgen am sonnigsten wird
nämlich zwischen der mose und dem
alpenrand aber auch hier in schleswig
holstein sehen sie häufiger die sonne im
osten dagegen hier bleibt es doch eher
trüb da kann es auch ein bisschen
tröpfeln bei ost nordost wind am freitag
sehen sie die sonne dann aber wohl
wahrscheinlich überall wieder bei
temperaturen von 10 bis 21 grad am
samstag wird es von südwesten
wechselhafter da kommen dann schon
gewitter heran und regenschauer und die
breiten sich am sonntag dann weiter
richtung norden und osten aus guten
abend